il a milité à gauche dès le lycée
multipliant les actions coup de point à
la fac de Poitier aujourd'hui mon invité
ne brandit plus les mégaphones en manif
puisqu'il est président de la commission
des lois à l'Assemblée
[Musique]
nationale bonjour Sacha oulier bonjour
alors de les téléspectateurs d' LCP
depuis 2017 vous ont toujours vu avec un
costume cravate des petites lunettes les
cheveux bien coiffés et j'ai été surpris
d'apprendre que vous ne vous
reconnaissez pas dans cette image vous
avez expliqué je n'ai pas le look de ce
que je suis réellement qu'est-ce que
vous entendez par là ben dans la vie
courante je suis un supporter de
football je suis passionné de de
cyclisme de moto que je regarde à la
télévision et que je pratique et puis
j'adore les cours typiques voilà donc
c'est sûr que quand quand on me voit
avec un costume et des petites lunettes
j'ai pas vraiment le profil de l'emploi
je fais très sage et puis on a
l'impression que je suis pas
d'extraction populaire comm parce que
j'all est-ce que c'est une façon de
faire référence aussi à vos origines non
parce que en fait d'abord moi je pense
que bien s'habiller institutionnalement
c'est quand même une reconnaissance
c'est pas c'est pas pour rien si les
ouvriers le dimanche il mettaient le
costume du dimanche euh et que par
ailleurs c'est pas parce qu'on met un
costume qu'on oublie qui on est au fond
et est-ce qu'on défend et est-ce que nos
parents nous ont inculqué en revanche je
suis assez F de mes origines populaires
aussi même si j'en fais pas référence
j'y fais pas référence tout le temps
lors d'une autre interview vous avez
évoqué un besoin de revanche sociale
est-ce que votre engagement politique a
été un moyen pour vous de de prendre
cette revanche non ça c'était plutôt mon
parcours professionnel en fait quand je
suis arrivé à la fac de droit à Poitier
il y a des gens qui m'ont dit très
crument que j'avais rien à faire ici et
c'était plus cru encore que ça euh parce
que j'avais pas les bonnes origines
parce queà l'époque j'avais un cuir de
moto et un casque barriolet voilà donc
ça pour le coup je l'ai fait dans les
études j'ai été parmi les les premiers
de la classe à la fac de droit euh
majeur de promo et après je me suis
battu pour être avocat et et pour être
en tant qu'avocat avoir tout de suite
mes clients à moi en plus de mon patron
qui me donnait du travail donc ça je
l'ai fait professionnellement après
politiquement c'est plutôt des combats
sur ce que je crois fondamentalement
juste qui qui m'a toujours animé on peut
pas dire que votre mère est exprimer une
vraie fierté hein quand son fils a été
élu député au contraire quelques années
après votre élection à l'Assemblée elle
a eu cette phrase qui moi m'a m'a
vraiment choqué quand tu es devenu
avocat j'étais fier quand tu es devenu
député ça m'était égal parce qu'avocat
c'est noble député c'est s ça renvoie à
ce que c'est la politique en fait la
politique il y a toujours un côté
polémiste il y a toujours quelque chose
qui fait que faudrait faire des coups
politiques pour réussir et et donc oui
il y a cette côté combine qui qui qui
colle à la vie politique alors que au
fond il y a quand même beaucoup ou
beaucoup de gens qui pourraient faire
autre chose mais qui ont décidé bah de
s'engager pour les autres donc c'est pas
évident et et c'est vrai que pour ma
maman qui était institutrice il y avait
le côté avec la robe d'avocat la
profession le la noblesse attachée à ce
métier et le côté député où c'est vrai
qu'elle me voit plus souvent sur les
marchés que à l'Assemblée nationale
alors vous même vous êtes engagé en
politique très jeune à 17 ans vous avez
bloqué votre lycée c'était pour
protester contre le CPE le le Contrat
Première Embauche plus tard à la fac de
Poitier vous avez mené des actions
parfois sp aire notamment en 2009 vous
avez lancé l'occupation de l'aéroport de
Poitier on vaevoir ça en
image les voitures de milieu ce sera la
Peugeot 104 avec le ballon jaune on va
l'aérodrome on passe par porte dérobée
de manière à occuper l'aérodrome pas
très très longtemps mais le but c'est de
disséminer le message qu'on a posté qui
en faitation
l'université et là on rigole c'est
parti
l plus
grand alors il est là le vrai
sachatoulier avec les cheveux en pétard
le mégaphone en l'air y a un peu tout ça
mais c'était une façon originale ce qui
est intéressant dans dans le reportage
c'est que dans A il y a pas de casse il
y a pas de d'agression ou il y a pas de
de confrontation avec les forces de
l'ordre ça dure pas très longtemps et au
final le le message il fonctionne donc
ça montre qu' peut avoir un militantisme
qui est qui est joyeux ouais et qui qui
peut être un peu spectaculaire mais qui
au fond est très pacifiste c'est c'est
la c'est presque la marque de fabrique
du militantisme à Poitier ce qu'on a
fait avec Stéphane séjourné ce qu'on a
fait avec d'autres où il y a jamais eu
de de de violence dans ce qu'on parce
que ces images quand on les voit comme
ça peuvent faire penser un peu à à sain
Soline contre les les bassin de Saint
Soline sauf qu'il y a pas la violence
ouais et ben je pense c'est l'essentiel
mais aujourd'hui vous auriez 18 ans vous
seriez allé manifester à sain Soline ou
non parce que je pense que il y a il y a
trop de trop de violence il y a trop
d'affrontement il y a trop d'idéologie
autour de tout ça et et là pour le coup
on a on sent qu'on défend des idées hein
on défend un message politique assez
fort sur les moyens des universités sur
les moyens d'allouer aux étudiants sur
la façon dont on veut assurer un service
public qui est accessible à tous sur
cette question mais en revanche il y a
un peu de ruse il y a un peu de malice
on contourne le dispositif forces de
l'ordre on casse rien et on insulte
personne ça c'est quand même essentiel
cette période de militantisme au PS et à
l'UNEF elle a été décisive pour la suite
de de votre engagement c'est à ce moment
que s'est constitué ce qu'on a appelé la
bande de Poitier alors on va on va voir
cette bande en image il y avait vous
mais aussi pierre person Stéphane
séjourné Guillaume chiche Aurélien taché
bon c'est une partie de la bande mais je
l'ai cité cela parce que tout cela vous
avez quitté le PS ensemble pour
rejoindre Emmanuel Macron et vous avez
tous occupé des postes importants des
responsabilités politiques importantes
comment est est-ce que vous expliquez ce
destin commun qui est quand même assez
hors du commun bon jeexplique pas on a
on a tous travaillé pour ça on s tous
engagés politiquement on suit des
parcours qui sont assez différents les
uns des autres c'est encore une photo au
congrès de du PS à Poitier en 2015 et et
maintenant on n'est pas tous forcément
d'accord là où il y avait des gens qui
sont restés au PS il y a des gens qui
sont compris d'autres chemins il y a des
gens avec qui ont est en desaccord en
revanche on était un groupe d'amis et on
a toujours travaillé dans le respect les
uns les autres vous dites que c'est la
loi Maron qui a qui a fait office de
révélation pour vous la loi Macron voté
en en 2015 sous le quinquen de de
François Hollande révélation de quoi
pour vous qu'est-ce qui s'est passé bah
d'abord en tant que jeune avocat parce
qu'il y avait plusieurs dispositions
pour les jeunes avocats qui permettaient
de s'installer qui permettaient un peu
de de libérer la place de faire don à
chacun sa chance en fonction de ses de
ses ses compétences puis dans la méthode
le fait de vouloir travailler un peu
avec tout le monde de pouvoir ouvrir un
peu les je dir les chakras mais même les
esprits de des uns et des autres et
trouva ça assez intéressant et ce qui
m'avait amené à le soutenir alors ça
avait faitraillé à l'époque beaucoup au
Parti socialiste ou au mou Gén
socialiste alors en 2017 vous avez donc
pris une place importante dans la
campagne d'Emmanuel Macron puisque vous
avez créé les jeunes avec Macron ça vous
a valu après votre élection à
l'Assemblée d'être un peu catalogué si
l'on peut dire comme faisant partie de
la garde rapprochée d'Emmanuel Macron
pourtant bah vous êtes rapidement opposé
à lui en tout cas à certaines décisions
qu'il a qu'il a pris euh le premier
quinen vous êtes déçu non il y a enfin
pour l'essentiel moi j'ai soutenu le le
président de la République il y avait
quelques mesures qui ont été portées où
j'avais une voix dissonnante c'était pas
les mesures qui étaient forcément les
les plus importantes mais surtout Santi
covid sur certaines dispositions sur la
police il y avait des choses sur
lesquels j'avais des des opinions qui
étaient un peu différentes et je les ai
fait valoir et je les ai toujours enfin
c'est une façon aussi de jamais renier
ses ses convictions et de de de pouvoir
se défendre mais mais au point à un
moment de claquer la porte des instances
dirigeantes dans marche par on vous a
senti un peu désenchanté presque bah
vous savez la vie de la la la politique
c'est c'est quand même assez dur euh on
vous demande à chaque fois de de faire
des efforts de travailler énormément et
puis de de faire des compromis et
parfois il y a des compromis qui sont un
peu plus difficiles que d'autres euh et
euh et donc c'est une façon de marquer
des désaccords après euh comme
vice-président de l'Assemblée comme
rapporteur de différents Tex av été
quelques mois plus jeune président de de
l'histoire de la 5e j'ai toujours servi
en fonction de ce que je pensais être le
meilleur hmm vous avez reconnu avoir
fait preuve d'immaturité au début de
votre premier mandat il y avait un
responsable de la majorité dans un
article qui vous surnommit le SAL
Maum vous avez changé par rapport à ça
vous euh bah d'abord je pense qu' avoir
du caractère c'est important ensuite il
faut imaginer ce que c'est que d'être
élu à à 28 ans avec toute la charge que
ça représente euh compris quand on est
vice-président de l'Assemblée et euh
faut reconnaître queon a pu faire des
erreurs et c'est arrivé mais lesquels
quoi bah le fait que on était un peu en
mode bulldzer on avait on voulait euh
prendre la place on voulait euh existit
politiquement on voulait défendre nos
idées parfois on a pu être impoli à
l'égard de certains ministres bon c'est
c'est la vie et le le le le but 1 c'est
de le savoir de de savoir ce qu'on a pas
bien fait et de pas le reproduire alors
depuis votreélection en 2022 on vous a
entendu sur la taxation des super
profits sur le report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite sur la
régularisation des des travailleurs sans
papier avec cette tribune qui a été
cossigné avec plus plusieurs
responsables de la nup donc vous
continuez de porter une voix de gauche
au de la majorité mais on a l'impression
que vous y prenez différemment que vous
avez un peu changé de méthode bah disons
que je m'assure que les idées qu'on
qu'on défend deviennent majoritaire au
départ j'étais on prenait des des des
objets politiques qu'on défendait et peu
importe finalement quel était le l'issue
le but était d'abord de pouvoir défendre
ce qu'on pensait juste là le but est de
faire progresser les idées c'estd de
peser réellement c'est pas juste grandir
le point la taxe sur les super profits
elle est dans la loi de finance 2023
elle finance le bouclier tarifaire donc
si les Français ils ont payé moins cher
leur électricité en tout cas moins cher
que les voisins européens c'est parce
que on on a pu l'inscrire dans la loi la
régularisation des travailleurs dans les
métiers entention aujourd'hui elle est
dans la loi et demain lors de sa
promulgation j'espère qu'elle pourra
l'être aussi et le but il est d'abord de
de gagner des choses pour queon
transforme la vie des gens et ça ça
prend plus de temps mais c'est peut-être
plus efficacee et dans cette stratégie
il y a ce poste que vous occupez
aujourd'hui président de la commission
des lois qui commission très importante
à l'Assemblée ça aussi c'est une leçon
tirée de du premier mandat oui aussi
parce que d'abord moi j'avais j'ai
travaillé sur plein de sujet à la
commission des lois j'ai travaillé sur
des choses qui étaient un peu anonymes
comme le droit des contrats mais en fait
ça protège quand même les parties les
plus faibles quand il signent un contrat
d'adhésion de consommateur c'est-à-dire
quand ils ont acheté un téléphone ou
souscrit un contrat de d'assurance par
exemple j'avais fait des choses sur les
collectivités pour notamment les statut
des maires les relations entre les
mairies et les intercommunalités tout ça
était assez confidentiel et donc j'ai
pris après la la vice-présidence de
l'Assemblée un peu un bâton de péderin
en travaillant le fond mais par là la
Commission des loi la présidence c'est
un outil pour vous
tout le chemin accompli pendant le
premier mandat un travaill en sujet par
sujet bloc par bloc un peu un peu dans
dans l'ombre et puis avec pinacité ça ça
a permis de construire la présidence de
la commission des lois aujourd'hui et de
connaître bien les sujets pour pouvoir
bah être efficace à nouveau le député de
la France insoumise Hugo bernalici dit
de vous c'est le moins pire des
macronistes vous le prenez comme un
compliment bah je je pense en tout cas
je je le lis comme ça je le merci pour
le pour le commentaire je pourrais lui
dire que c'est le moins pire des des
mélanchonistes mais mais il y en a
d'autres avec lesquels je m'entends
également et et ça montre aussi que on
essaie parfois de mettre son étiquette
dans sa poche pour avancer h on va
passer à notre quiz à présent vous allez
devoir compléter des phrases que je vais
commencer de mon de mon côté on va
commencer par parler de foot vous êtes
un grand fan de l'Olympique de Marseille
on y va l'hémicycle c'est un peu peu
comme le stade Vélodrome euh ouais c'est
c'est c'est bruyant et et c'est il
manque presque les fumigènes quoi c'est
ce que j'allais dire ouais il paraît que
vous avez déjà craqué des fumigènes dans
les tribunes du stad Vélodrome ça m'est
arrivé deux fois ouais mais avant ou
après votre élection à l'Assemblée non
il y a prescription c'était en sur la
période BSA entre 2014 et 2015 la saison
2014 2015 eu on continue quand on me
compare à Harry Potter ah ça me fait
plaisir parce que ça veut dire que
quelque part il y a quelque chose d'un
peu magique
et il y a quelque chose d'un peu magique
dans dans la politique parce que le fait
de pouvoir changer le destin des gens ça
ça pararente à de la magie enfin faire
de la politique c'est renoncer à
euh c'est beaucoup renoncer à de la sa
vie privée c'est assez pesant pour pour
ma famille parce que qui lit des choses
sur les réseaux sociaux et pour ma femme
qui parfois aimerait bien que on a plus
de temps à nous merci beaucoup Sacha
d'être venu dans la politique et moi
merci
[Musique]